[Music]
on this Wednesday night a teenaged
Terror suspect in Ottawa accused of
planning to make a bomb the explosives
he's accused of using to Target Jewish
people Colorado's Top Court dumps Trump
from the state's primary the far-left
lunatics are desperate to stop us the
ramifications for his Run for the White
House searching for clues why do you do
what you do I love one man's mission to
find missing indigenous people and a
whale of a discovery we better start
practicing how a conversation with a
humpback could help humans communicate
with
aliens global national with Donna Fen
reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening and thank you for joining us the
Ottawa teen accused of plotting an
attack on Jewish people appeared in
court by video today he'll remain in
custody until his bail hearing next
month the 15-year-old was arrested last
week on several terrorism related
charges including communicating
instructions from making explosives
McKenzie gray joins us with more on what
we're learning about the investigation
that led to his arrest McKenzie Jeff
Global News has learned authorities were
so concerned about the alleged plot from
the Teen that senior National Security
officials and politicians were routinely
briefed on it charges filed an Ottawa
court against a 15-year-old who cannot
be named due to his age alleged he
obtained aceton oxidizer key elements in
making the homemade explosive
tatp that bomb has been used in numerous
terrorist attacks like in 2016 in
Brussels and an attempted murder in
Winnipeg the charges also say he
obtained metal ball bearings frequently
used in homemade explosives to function
as shrapnel they were a Hallmark of the
Boston Marathon bombings to be able to
stockpile um weapons and things like
that domestically that that takes a a
level of maturity and connection and
awareness which usually we don't see
with um younger uh people the RCMP found
the alleged ingredients during a search
warrant executed over the weekend but
figuring out how to make this type of
explosive can easily be done online a
major concern for police and finding the
materials is no problem at all we're
here at a local Ottawa hardware store
and we got all three key materials with
no questions asked very simple the cost
only $150 when put
together a tatp bomb can cause serious
damage Professor Jimmy Oxley who is
advised the RCMP and FBI researches and
works with these materials we have
chemicals that that are are built to
kill bugs are built to be bleach and
clean but wherever there's something
good somebody can think about how to do
something bad the ottawa's alleged plan
to attack the Jewish community dates
back to on or about October 24th
according to court documents but sources
tell Global News the high schooler was
believed to have been radicalized prior
to the Israel Hamas conflict the teen
also had trips planned to visit family
in Iraq both before and after the
conflict started but never went on a
trip planned with his father his mother
promised him to take him to Iraq last
year she couldn't make it I don't care I
spent all the money I borrow money I
want to take them the teen's next court
appearance will be on January 15th for a
bail hearing Jeff but until then he'll
stay in police
custody Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mac the Israeli Prime Minister delivered
a dire message to Hamas today telling
them they have two options surrender or
die in the brief video statement
Benjamin Netanyahu said Israel's war on
Hamas would continue until the end
vowing that Hamas will be eliminated
this as UNICEF warns clean water in Gaza
is running out and many more children
will die from deprivation or disease in
the coming days a vote at the UN
Security Council calling for another
break in the fighting was delayed for
the third time this week US President
Joe Biden told reporters that at this
point there's no expectation of a
hostage deal but the US is pushing for
one Crystal ganing Reports on the
humanitarian crisis and the latest push
for a pause in the fighting and a
warning some of these images are
distressing moments after multiple
strikes hit Rafa the search for
survivors began this collapsed building
was said to be home to many families
including those who had fled to the
South as directed by
Israel all of a sudden the first rocket
landed says this man destroying
everything his family managed to escape
taking with them this little girl she
was born 3 days ago the air strikes near
the Kuwait Hospital were captured by an
aler news crew during a live report oh
my god did you hear
that oh my
God that's the hospital that's the
hospital in the last week during visits
by high-ranking Americans there was talk
about Israel lowering the intensity of
its campaign and using more precise
strikes to protect civilians Fierce fire
is how Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu described his nation's
operations in Gaza telling Hamas
fighters to surrender or
die we are continuing the war to the end
it will continue until Hamas is
eliminated until Victory whoever thinks
that we will stop is detached from
reality The American Secretary of State
called the images coming out of Gaza
gut-wrenching we hear many countries
urging the end to uh this conflict which
we would all like to see I hear virtu no
one saying demanding of Hamas that it
stop hiding behind civilians talks are
reportedly in the works for another
humanitarian pause in fighting that
would allow for hostages to be traded
and for Aid to be safely delivered
across Gaza however an agreement does
not appear to be imminent Jeff Crystal
Gand Singh in London thanks Crystal a
senior Hamas official says the group is
watching the growing calls from Western
Government to end the attacks on Gaza in
a video posted on Monday the Hamas
leader specifically praised The Joint
statement released last week by Canada
Australia and New Zealand calling for a
sustainable
ceasefire we welcome this developments
and consider them in the right
direction Canada considers Hamas a
terrorist organization Canada voted last
week in support of a non-binding UN
resolution calling for a ceasefire the
death toll in Gaza has now reached
20,000 according to the Hamas run Health
Ministry India's prime minister is
breaking his silence addressing for the
first time the allegations that his
government directed A foiled plot to
murder a sick separatist leader in the
United States Narendra Modi told the
Financial Times newspaper if a citizen
of ours has done anything good or bad we
are ready to look into it our commitment
is to the rule of law last month the US
justice department said an Indian
government official had directed the
plot to kill a dual citizen of the US in
Canada that came two months after
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
alleged there was credible evidence
linking India's government to the
shooting death of sick activist Hardeep
sing ner in BC India fiercely rejected
ottawa's
accusations we'll take a look at this
Drone footage revealing the scale of
Devastation in Northwest China after a
magnitude 6.2 earthquake on Monday at
least 130 people were killed and
thousands of homes destroyed freezing
cold temperatures are now compounding
the misery for the more than 87,000
people who've been displaced many of
them now sleeping in tense while
temperatures plunge to minus5° C A Court
decision in the US could upset the
already tumultuous 2024 presidential
election campaign Colorado's Supreme
Court ruled that Donald Trump is
disqualified from appearing on the
ballot and ineligible to hold office
again the decision stems from his role
in the storming of the US capital 3
years ago Jackson prosco on what this
means for Trump's Republican nomination
bid campaigning Like a Man Without worry
Donald Trump wouldn't directly address
the court ruling that could end his
presidential Ambitions it's no wonder
crooked Joe Biden and the far-left
lunatics are desperate to stop us by any
means necessary late Tuesday Colorado's
Supreme Court disqualified Trump from
holding office again the court removed
him from the state's Republican primary
ballot we will never give up we will
never concede all because of his role in
the storming of the US capital after he
lost the 2020 election it is a lawsuit
brought by Republicans and independents
to enforce state law and the
Constitution uh in Colorado Colorado
lawyer Eric Olsen brought the case on
behalf of a group of Voters engaging in
Insurrection after having taken an oath
is disqualifying under our constitution
Trump has vowed to appeal all the way to
the US Supreme Court where the
conservative majority could overturn the
decision the current president and
Trump's likely opponent in November is
treading carefully has let the court
make that decision but he certainly
supported an Insurrection no question
about it if the US Supreme Court upholds
the decision it could be disastrous for
Trump several other states have hinted
they too could follow suit and remove
him from their ballots the high court
already faces a laundry list of cases
relating to Trump's future and may also
be asked to decide whether the former
president is immune from prosecution a
case Trump is trying to delay our
constitution commands no armies it has
no police force it relies on citizens
and judges to ensure that we live in a
nation of Law and not under one man that
one man is now testing the limits of the
law raising the difficult question
question of whether the courts or voters
should decide who's eligible to lead
Jackson prco Global News
Washington the union Coalition
representing
420,000 public sector workers including
teachers in Quebec warns it will go on
an unlimited strike in the New Year if a
deal isn't reached in the coming days
they're calling on the provincial
government to do more to break the
deadlock in
negotiations I think that the government
should feel trapped and they are fully
accountable of that if they want to see
an improvement if they want to work in a
reasonable way with us there's a way to
do it and the next hours are very
important the labor Coalition known as
the common front represents public
health education and Social Service
workers they're asking for better
working conditions and inflation
adjusted pay an unlimited strike meaning
a strike with no end date would close
all public schools in Quebec
indefinitely and cause more delays in
the Health Care system Toronto police
made a dramatic arrest today involving a
Chase car crash and an alleged abduction
police say the driver of this stolen
U-Haul was chased by police cruisers and
a helicopter it ended in a collision
where a 49-year-old man was arrested
another person was rescued after police
say they were abducted by the suspect at
gunpoint police believe the same suspect
was responsible for stabbing and
seriously injuring an off-duty police
officer a couple of weeks ago a
volunteer hoping to help families in
agony coming up one man's dedication to
tracking down missing indigenous
people a first nation's man is
volunteering his time to search for
missing indigenous people their families
say police haven't done enough to look
for their loved ones his dedication has
taken him across the country triggering
police investigations along the way NE
aara takes us to northern BC near Prince
George where the Man known as mua bear
is helping families get
answers this is the Eagle song Maka bear
says it represents love he sings half of
it when he starts a search for a missing
indigenous
[Music]
person and he only finishes the song
When A search is complete he says in
some cases it's dangerous work and has
led to threats we agreed to conceal his
identity right here is where you found
her first stuff now visiting it with a
devastated father this is where my baby
was this is the site where Maka bear
last sang the rest of the eagle song on
November 5th 2 days into his search he
found the personal belongings of Chelsea
Haron officers were called in and a
police canine found her remains Heron's
cause of death is under investigation
the family feels the circumstances are
suspicious found my daughter's
wallet her ID her
clothes they say bear filled a gap when
police didn't do enough to search for
the
29-year-old she was last seen leaving
her father's residence here on saa's
First Nation about 900 kilm North of
Vancouver during the early morning hours
of October 11th it took an outsider to
come from far away to find her we
wouldn't have had the closure if it
wasn't for him and he doesn't ask for or
anything vanderhof RCMP is under
investigation by the province's police
Watchdog the RCMP says its resources
were engaged whenever possible and every
lead was followed they confirmed a
volunteer was responsible for finding
Heron's belongings leading them to her
body and these people paid and I came
why do you do what you do I would would
love I'm not here to make friends and
I'm not here to solve anything I'm here
to look for for your loved
on the man from white dog first nation
in Ontario says A Spiritual Awakening
four years ago guided him to this work
he since LED 15 searches in Saskatchewan
Manitoba Alberta and
BC I hit shik from town to town he says
each Community he visits helps pay for
his his food and lodging he's working to
fundraise to help cover the cost of his
travel and an ATV any times I feel like
giving up but I'm not going to give up
I'm going to do this forever
until until I'm done on this
Earth and like the song bookending each
search he says his work is rooted in
traditional indigenous knowledge a way
of life focused on love for Community
Above All Else Nara Global News SA First
Nation advertising battle still ahead
the similarities between Pierre pv's ad
campaign and Justin Trudeau back in
[Music]
2015 the federal Liberals are launching
a new series of attack ads in 18 Tory
held writings claiming conservatives are
turning their backs on Ukraine after the
party voted against an updated trade
deal with the war torn country it's the
latest in a liberal push to Target
Pierre PV after the federal
conservatives ran a multi-million dollar
ad campaign earlier this year David aen
reports on the impact and influence of a
new political ad campaign
battle it's time for a change in this
country in 2015 these political ads
helped push Justin Trudeau's liberals to
a majority government the 2015 Trudeau
ads were among the best we've ever
tested poster Greg Lyall tested Those
ads by asking a thousand Canadians what
they thought of them this month he did
the same thing asking another thousand
Canadians about a new series of
political ads this time featuring
conservative leader Pierre PV I'm Pierre
PV and this is my story I was born to
ly's polling looked at the emotional
response to the ads is a viewer more or
less hopeful after seeing the ad more or
less angry he says the conservative ads
test even better than the 2015 liberal
ads what we're seeing with PV is that PA
of is doing in 2023 what Trudeau did in
2015 he's now grabbing the Hope agenda
he's becoming the party of Hope and
Trudeau has now become the party of the
status quo in some Pierre POV uses the
same direct to camera approach my
parents would walk out this door to work
as that Justin Trudeau used in 2015 I'll
lead this country with a new plan for
our economy a technique that worked then
and is working now if you look at these
ads people that support all the other
opposition parties to the Tories all all
their opponents the supporters of all
those parties say they like those ads
and they agree with what the ads are
saying and that is unusual and that is
one of the things that made the 2015
liberal ADS stand out and so for the
first time since trudo became liberal
leader radical gender IDE the Liberals
this fall launched paid negative ads
attacking POV trying to paint him as a
northern Donald Trump fake news fake
news news the left-wing censorship
regime their woke censorship ideology
and divide Canadians those liberal
attack ads were online only and their
impact has yet to be measured but the
first ever appearance of a liberal
attack ad was a clear recognition by
that party that the conservative
branding campaign was working a little
too well for the Liberals Comfort Jeff
David aen in Ottawa thanks
David up next how a deep sea Discovery
could unlock the secret to communicating
with
[Music]
animals the massive volcanic eruption in
Southwestern Iceland is easing there are
now three vents spewing lava down from 5
when it started erupting on Monday
people are still being told to stay away
and it's not known yet whether any homes
have been destroyed artificial
intelligence could soon help us to
understand how animals communicate
scientists are testing the theory on
whales using AI to translate the noises
they make into words Eric senson
explains how it could one day help
humans communicate with life on another
planet there's just a brief glimpse of
Twain a humpback whale off Alaska
scientists played a recorded humpback
signal and 10 seconds later Twain
answered the conversation from 2021
lasted a remarkable 20
minutes as the whale circled the
boat a new paper suggests it's the first
such communicative exchange between
humans and humpback whales in the
humpback language it's a window into
possibilities of how we might learn more
about how other animals in general in
humpback whales in particular
communicate humans have barely scratched
the surface of understanding other
species the sing song of
humpbacks the whistle exchanges of
dolphins and the clicks of sperm
whales the cation translation initiative
hopes artificial intelligence will make
a difference the project is creating a
vast research area off Dominica where
different PODS of sperm whales live the
sea floor will be rigged with listening
devices spanning some 20 kilometers soft
robots like robotic fish will move among
the whales to make audio visual
recordings the basic goal listen to
millions of whale vocalizations and with
AI translate what they might be
communicating and ultimately exchange
ideas the AI tools can help us to
decipher what they're saying to each
other Tom musle once narrowly escaped
death when a humpback lurched onto his
kayak his research suggests species are
closer than ever to understanding one
another suddenly we're realizing that
there are neighbors and that maybe we
have a chance to understand what they're
saying in their lives and maybe even
communicate with them talking to whales
could broaden our narrow grasp on
communicating to prepare us eventually
for extraterrestrial contact we better
start practicing on all the
communication systems on Earth because
we are not ready right now to get the
communication in case we get an
extraterrestrial signals someday the
stewardship of the planet May benefit
from what the smartest mammals on land
and in the sea can learn from each other
Eric senson Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Jeff simple tonight's
your Canada these boats lit up in Port
degrave Peninsula newfinland and
Labrador we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at
global.com thanks for watching far
anaser will be at the anchor desk with
you tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night